starting today the nation's largest
retailer is launching a new delivery
service using autonomous drones cbs news
we're happy to say got an exclusive
behind-the-scenes look at walmart's new
on-demand delivery service the first
location is near the company's arkansas
headquarters errol barnett joins us from
listen to this place p ridge arkansas i
like that where flights are about to
take off errol good morning to you
this is very cool welcome inside the
belly of flight operations i'm in a
platform built directly behind a walmart
store as part of its new partnership
with autonomous drone company zipline as
of today folks here in northwest
arkansas can have their orders delivered
by some of the most advanced flying
technology in the world
[Music]
while the supply chain backlog continues
to choke ports and trucking routes
many companies are now looking to the
skies for solutions it's unbelievably
exciting we've been working towards the
state for many many years liam o'connor
is zipline's chief operating officer we
have done over 220 000 commercial
deliveries in overseas markets for us
the promise of ultra fast delivery is
really to give access to all kinds of
communities to all kinds of products
once a customer places an order via the
zipline walmart app items are packaged
inside this specially designed box with
a parachute so the first step we're
doing is scanning the package so by now
someone's ordered something it's been
packaged up and now it's in your hand
that's correct flight operations lead
evan britton showed us how it's launched
next we'll
install the parachute
and load the package into the
payload bay
latches in and the next step will be to
install the battery
it's inspection complete zipline 963.
roger
zipline 963 in three
two one
for now these zips as they're called are
able to drop payloads within a 50 mile
radius of p ridge arkansas but walmart
and zipline hope to one day expand the
service nationwide if our customers
enjoy the service we'll scale it so in
future holidays this is probably going
to play a really big part in getting
things in a hurry tom ward runs
walmart's last mile delivery operations
customers expect us to save the money
they need us to save them time and when
it comes to saving time what better way
to do it than via drone zipline is part
of a growing list of companies looking
to make commercial drone delivery more
accessible and with more drones flying
over homes businesses and people below
there are questions around safety when
it comes to technology anything that can
go wrong will so how do you plan for a
system malfunction or the aircraft not
having enough juice to get back the
aircraft can fly for two and a half
hours on this battery if there were ever
any aberration that would cause us to
need to deploy the parachute we're
talking about an opportunity to really
take the energy out of the event to
decelerate the aircraft and make sure
that that there is
minimal risk to anybody on the ground
each zip returns to home base and hooks
itself to this suspension cable normal
recovery zipline 963. where it awaits
its next mission
and this is one of the zips as they call
it this model is called a sparrow and
and look it only weighs about 45 pounds
total with the wings which span about 11
feet it's wrapped in styrofoam you see
some of the avionics here and this is
the hook made of aircraft-grade aluminum
that it has to catch to land safely so
arkansas don't be concerned if you see
this bad boy flying overhead
okay errol i think it's very cool but
how do you know that bad boy isn't going
to drop something on somebody's head
that's what i'm worried about sam just
chilling in the yard and the thing comes
flying down
i don't know i guess they figured that
out too it is a valid question i think
there'll be some experimenting yeah
very cool i like arrow with a subtle
flex this is about 45 pounds and look
how easy i'm carrying it right now thank
you because i was thinking the same
thing go errol burnett